>> Laura: PRESIDENT TRUMP
HOSTED A MEETING WITH VIDEO
GAME MAKERS AND THEIR
CRITICS AT THE WHITE HOUSE
TODAY.
HE WAS BUSY.
LOOKING FOR WAYS TO REDUCE
YOUTH VIOLENCE.
PRESIDENT EXPRESSED SHOCK AT
WHAT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
EXPOSED TO TODAY.
>> THE VIDEO GAMES, THE
MOVIES, THE INTERNET STUFF
IS SO VIOLENT.
IT'S SO INCREDIBLE.
I SEE IT.
I GET TO SEE THINGS THAT YOU
WOULDN'T BE -- YOU WOULD
WOULD BE AMAZED AT.
I HAVE A VERY YOUNG SON WHO
I LOOK AT SOME OF THE THINGS
IS HE WATCHING, AND I SAY
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE AND
THIS IS WHAT KIDS ARE
WATCHING.
>> Laura: LET'S DISCUSS
WHETHER THERE ANY S. ANY
LINK ON VIOLENCE ON THE
SCREEN AND REAL VIOLENCE
WITH BEN SHAPIRO AND RETIRED
ARMY LIEUTENANT COLONEL
DAVID GROSSMAN AUTHORED
BOOKS ON THE PSYCHOLOGY OF
VIOLENCE ARMY RANGER, BLACK
BELT AND -- OKAY, YOU WIN.
JUST ON THAT SCORE.
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE YOU BOTH
ON.
LET'S START WITH YOU, DAVID,
BECAUSE SOME OF THESE GAMES
ARE REALLY WILD.
I MEAN, THEY ARE PRETTY
GRAPHIC, PRETTY GORY.
YOU KNOW THEM.
CALL OF DUTY.
I DON'T DO ANY OF THESE.
>> GRAND THEFT AUTO.
>> Laura: SIMULATED
VIOLENCE.
>> MURDER SIMILARITY.
>> Laura: EVAN RAMSEY OTHERS
LIKE SOME OF THESE OTHER
KILLERS.
KLEE BOLD, ADAM LANZA.
>> THE NORWAY KILLER TRAINED
ON THOSE.
PREPARE HIMSELF TO COMMIT
CRIME.
THE KILLER IN FLORIDA HE
SPENT 15 HOURS A DAY ON
VIOLENT VIDEO GAMES.
ALL CONSUMING ALL PERVASIVE
THING IN THIS GUY'S LIFE ARE
VIOLENT VIDEO GAMES.
LESS THAN A YEAR AGO, THE
AMERICAN PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION MADE A
DEFINITIVE STATEMENT.
THERE IS A CLEAR UNEQUIVOCAL
LINK BETWEEN VIOLENT VIDEO
GAMES AND VIOLENT BEHAVIOR.
THE BLOOD PRESSURE GOES UP.
HEART RATE GOES UP.
VIOLENT ACTIONS GO UP.
THE DATA IS PERSISTENT AND
CLEAR ACROSS MANY DIFFERENT
FORUMS.
YOU CAN'T DENY IT.
IT IS OVERWHELMING.
>> Laura: BEN SHAPIRO, I
KNOW YOU ARE A SKEPTICAL
GAMES.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE PLAY
THESE VIDEO GAMES.
GIRLS AREN'T AS IN TO THESE
VIDEO GAMES I'M SORRY AS
BOYS ARE.
I THINK IF MY SONS HAD
ACCESS TO THEM, I'M SURE
THEY WOULD PLAY THEM ALL THE
TIME.
SOMETHING ABOUT THE BOY'S
BRAIN AND THESE GAMES.
WHY ARE YOU NOT WORRIED
ABOUT IT.
>> I MEAN, I'M NOT WORRIED
ABOUT IT BECAUSE THE
CONSUMPTION OF THESE VIOLENT
VIDEO GAMES HAS BEEN GOING
ON CONTINUOUSLY SINCE THE
EARLY 90'S AND YOUTH
VIOLENCE HAS BEEN GOING DOWN
SINCE THE EARLY '90S.
THE CORRELATION DOESN'T
FITTED.
AS FAR AS INDIVIDUAL
INSTANCES CAN YOU FIND
PATTERNS IN VERY SPORADIC
INSTANCES AMONG VIRTUALLY
ALL DATA SETS.
THERE IS MIXED DATA ABOUT
THIS.
IT'S TRUE THAT AMERICAN
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION
RECOMMENDS THAT PARENTS NOT
ALLOW KIDS PLAY THESE GAMES.
I WOULDN'T BECAUSE THEY'RE
IMMORAL.
I'M NOT SURE THE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD BE IN THE BUSINESS OF
STEPPING IN 2011, JUSTICE
SCALIA JUSTICE DECISION 5-4
UNCONSTITUTIONAL FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
REGULATE THE CAPACITY OF
PARENTS TO BE ABLE TO GET
THESE VIDEO GAMES FOR THESE
KIDS OR KIDS TO GET THEM
WITHOUT PARENTAL PERMISSION.
YOU SAW THAT HAS CONTENT
VIOLATION UNDER THE FIRST
AMENDMENT.
>> Laura: LET'S TALK MORE
ABOUT THIS.
THE ASSASSINATIONS THAT TAKE
PLACE IN THE GAMES.
>> YOU KNOW, MY BOOK, LAURA,
ASSASSINATION GENERATION, WE
OUTLINED THE DISSENTING
OPINIONS IN THAT CASE.
THERE IS MUCH MORE TO THIS
SITUATION THAT WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND.
CLARENCE THOMAS AND STEVEN
BREYER, THE MOST LIBERAL AND
CONSERVATIVE JUSTICE
DISSENTED.
STEVEN BREYER SAID THEY USE
THESE TO TRAIN MILLER.
I'M NOT A MEDICAL EXPERT BUT
I KNOW WHO IS AND IT'S NOT
THE PEOPLE THE VIDEO GAMERS
PUT OUT.
YOU NEED TO KNOW MORE ABOUT
THE CASE.
THE DATA IS SO OVERWHELMING.
WHEN I WAS A KID NOBODY
BUCKLED SEAT BELT ALL JUST
FINE.
THE SEAT BELT UNBUCKLED
DIED.
BUT ALL THE ONES THAT
DIED --
>> Laura: KIDS HAVE
PREDISPOSITIONS TO THIS.
>> YEAH.
>> Laura: MAYBE THEY HAVE A
TRIGGER INSIDE OF THEM, THEY
STEEP THEMSELVES.
>> ONE MORE INGREDIENT TO IT
GREAT BOOK INSIDE THE MIND
OF A TEEN KILLER.
THE NEW FACTOR IN EVERY
SINGLE INDICATES, THE NEW
FACTOR, THE FACT THAT
VIOLENT CRIME IS DOWN IS NOT
TRUE.
>> Laura: ARE THEY USING
THESE IN ARMY RANGER
TRAINING DO THEY DO
SIMULATION.
>> WE DO IT WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND VIDEO
TRAINING.
YOU DON'T SEE IT IN RANGER
SCHOOL BUT INTEGRAL PART OF
OUR TRAINING MAKE KILLING
RESPONSE PART OF TRAINING.
WE HAVE TO DO IT.
HEALTHY PEOPLE HAVE TO BE
TRAINED TO DO AND THE VIDEO
GAMES DO THE SAME THINGS TO
THE KIDS.
>> Laura: BEN, WHAT I THINK
ABOUT THIS, SCIENCE OR NOT,
FOR YOUNG CHILDREN TO
CONTINUALLY SEE IMAGES OF
HEADS EXPLODING, CHESTS
OPENING UP, YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE IMMORALITY OF ALL OF
THIS.
WHETHER IT'S CONSTITUTIONAL
OR NOT CONSTITUTIONAL, MAYBE
IT AS A SOCIETAL WE HAVE TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT NUMBING
OURSELVES TO THIS VERY
GRAPHIC VIOLENCE.
IT'S NOT A CARTOON.
THIS LOOKS LIKE A REAL
PERSON'S HEAD EXPLODING AND
IT'S OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND DOING IT 10 HOURS
A DAY AND PLAYING WITH
PEOPLE IN OTHER COUNTRIES,
THAT'S WHERE YOU ARE GETTING
YOUR STIMULATION.
THAT'S BOYS NEED TO BE
OUTSIDE PLAYING AND DOING
PHYSICAL STUFF.
INSTEAD SITTING THERE ON
THESE SCREENS ALL DAY.
I DON'T SEE HOW ANY OF THAT
IS GOOD.
>> I FULLY AGREE WITH ALL OF
THAT I JUST THINK IT'S A
QUESTION OF PARENTAL
AUTHORITY AND I THINK IT'S A
QUESTION OF HOW WE AS A
SOCIETY CHOOSE TO RAISE OUR
KIDS NOT A QUESTION OF
GOVERNMENTAL REGULATION.